Veigné et les espoirs doucher des
salariés de Sourdillon avec plus de 6
millions d'euros de dettes et en
l'absence de repreneur le Tribunal de
Commerce a prononcé hier la liquidation
judiciaire de l'entreprise de robinet 47
salariés vont perdre leur emploi
Faustine une eau était avec eux ce matin
les traits fermés et le visage grave les
salles entreprises ils viennent
d'apprendre leur licenciement de la
bouche du liquidateur judiciaire un coup
dur pour ses 47 salariés dont la grande
majorité travaillait dans l'entreprise
depuis plus de 30 ans c'est un désastre
au niveau des emplois sachant que la
moyenne d'âge dans l'entreprise est 54
ans ça va être très compliqué pour tout
le monde pour retrouver de l'emploi ou
se reclasser la négociation est
difficile une société à moins de 50
salariés donc voilà les plantes
formations et tout ce qui s'ensuit ça
sera très limité on est sur un
licenciement économique donc
spécialisée dans la fabrique de robinets
l'entreprise Sourdillon créée en 1919
avait implanté une usine sur le site
actuel de Veigné en 1949 son histoire
avec la commune durait donc depuis plus
de 70 ans il y avait deux grosses
entreprises surveniers et bien c'est la
deuxième qui ferme donc là qu'est-ce
qu'on peut trouver comment on peut les
accompagner comment on peut moi je suis
prêt à leur mettre une salle à
disposition s'ils ont besoin de se
réunir je suis prêt à voir avec Pôle
emploi et tout ça maintenant
malheureusement c'est qu'ils sont tout
seul face à la difficulté de l'emploi
pourtant les salariés y ont cru jusqu'au
bout rachetés en 2016 par le groupe
français Selmi l'entreprise était en
redressement judiciaire depuis octobre
2022 une seule société avait fait une
offre de rachat avant de la retirer
Annie hillant tout espoir de reprise on
n'est pas star plusieurs sentiments la
colère la tristesse mais on en veut à
ces deux protagonistes qui sont
actionnaires du groupe Scénic qui nous
ont fait croire à des choses qui même je
pense n'y croyez pas et ça nous emmenait
dans le trou et aujourd'hui on a une
entreprise plus centenaire qui disparaît
et c'est bien dommage les salariés
espèrent désormais tenter quelques
négociations un contrat de sécurisation
professionnelle va leur être proposée
pour les accompagner dans leur recherche
d'emploi